Les grands singes, c'est vraiment capital pour moi
de faire tout pour les protéger.
Le braconnage, c'est une chasse illégale.
Et les grands singes sont souvent des victimes collatérales.
Le bonobo, il est une espèce, malheureusement,
en danger d'extinction.
Si on n'est pas capables de protéger nos plus proches cousins,
qu'est-ce qu'on va réussir à faire alors avec le reste de la biodiversité ?
Dans cette vidéo, je vous emmène au cœur du continent africain
pour vous parler de la situation des grands singes.
Les grands singes, c’est un ensemble d’espèces de primates non-humains,
qui comprend : les chimpanzés, les bonobos, les gorilles de l'est, les gorilles de l'ouest
et les espèces d'orang-outan. Il y a 3 espèces d'orang-outan maintenant.
Et leurs caractéristiques par rapport aux autres primates non-humains,
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de queue, ils marchent sur les phalanges ou sur les poings,
contrairement aux autres petits singes qui marchent sur les paumes.
Et ils ont une taille du cerveau, relativement à leur corps,
plus importante que les autres espèces.
Sauf qu’aujourd’hui, la plupart des grands singes sont en train de disparaître
et les primatologues rencontrent énormément de difficultés sur le terrain pour les protéger.
Et pour bien comprendre cette problématique,
je suis parti en République démocratique du Congo pour découvrir Lola Ya Bonobo,
le seul sanctuaire au monde qui recueille et soigne des bonobos.
Donc ça, c’est l’enclos, le premier groupe de bonobos
qui occupe une superficie de forêt de 10 hectares.
C’est un groupe paisible composé de 22 individus.
Ce sont des orphelins qui sont sauvés, rescapés du massacre,
après la mort de leurs parents.
Les bonobos, c’est une espèce du même genre que les chimpanzés.
La caractéristique des bonobos, c’est d’abord qu’ils ne vivent que
en République démocratique du Congo, on les trouve seulement dans ce pays
et ils sont, comme les chimpanzés, très proches de l’homme.
Globalement, ils sont considérés comme plus tolérants, plus pacifiques,
avec notamment un rôle très important des femelles.
Dans la société des bonobos, ce sont les femelles qui dirigent.
L’objectif, c’est en fait, grâce à l’alliance des femelles qui se tisse dans le groupe,
c’est de pouvoir maintenir la bonne cohésion, la discipline, surtout entre les mâles.
À chaque fois qu’il y a un conflit, une dispute, ils vont faire des négociations par approche sexuelle.
Ils se mettent ensemble, ils font l’amour et non la guerre
et ça, c’est un acte qui se déroule en pêle-mêle parce que ça implique les mâles entre eux,
les femelles entres elles, les grands et petits.
Tous les individus du groupe sont impliqués
parce qu’à chaque fois qu’il y a un stress dans le groupe, ils doivent s’apaiser, se calmer.
Les bonobos, ils sont à 90 % végétariens,
les 10 % qui restent sont équilibrés par des insectes, des œufs, du miel.
Ils font aussi recours à la viande, mais c’est très rare.
Ici, au sanctuaire, ils sont nourris principalement aux fruits et aux légumes.
Toutes les espèces de grands singes sont en danger. Le bonobo en fait partie.
On estime les populations minimales actuelles entre 15 et 20 000 individus
mais c’est une estimation basse.
La difficulté de mieux connaître la taille de la population, c’est de pouvoir faire un échantillonnage
dans tout le pays, ce qui est très difficile. Donc en fait, on ne sait pas exactement.
Mais on est sûrs qu'entre 2003 et 2015 environ,
plus de 50 % de la population a disparu.
Pourquoi ils sont menacés ?
Là encore, c’est assez commun avec toutes les espèces de grands singes.
De manière générale, on parle de la déforestation
qui, bien sûr, va entraîner une perte d’habitat mais aussi une fragmentation de l’habitat
mais aussi la mise en place, par exemple, de routes dans le cadre de l’exploitation forestière
ou de l’exploitation minière qui peut favoriser la deuxième menace qui est le braconnage.
Le braconnage est une chasse illégale qui peut avoir plusieurs objectifs
comme capturer des primates orphelins qui sont ensuite revendus au marché noir
ou tuer des espèces ciblées pour récupérer ce qu’on appelle de la viande de brousse
comme celles des singes.
Et cette viande, elle peut être consommée soit par les populations locales,
soit sur des marchés dans les grandes villes.
Il y a différentes techniques de chasse.
Il y a la chasse au fusil où là, le chasseur va décider s’il tire ou pas sur une cible.
Mais il y a aussi quelque chose qui est différent qui ne va pas directement viser les grands singes.
C’est ce qu’on appelle des pièges non sélectifs. Ce sont des collets.
Donc, comme des nœuds coulants faits avec des câbles qui vont être posés au sol
avec un mécanisme de déclenchement où lorsqu’un animal, quel qu’il soit, va mettre le pied dans le collet,
ça déclenche le mécanisme et donc ça l’attache autour de la patte.
Ces câbles-là vont pouvoir causer des mutilations chez les chimpanzés, chez les bonobos.
Donc ça peut, dans certains cas, arriver jusqu’à une amputation, c’est-à-dire qu’au fur et à mesure,
il n’y a plus de circulation sanguine et puis ça se nécrose et puis la main, par exemple, ou un doigt va tomber.
Et ce qui est difficile avec cette chasse-là,
c’est qu’elle n’est pas du tout faite pour faire du braconnage sur les grands singes.
C’est une chasse non sélective et les grands singes sont souvent des victimes collatérales.
À cause de ces menaces, les bonobos se retrouvent en danger
et la majorité de la population qu’on a ici, ce sont des orphelins qui sont récupérés,
saisis, grâce au concours de la loi.
Comme pour les autres grands singes, les bonobos ont besoin d’être très proches de leur mère
jusqu’à au moins 4/5 ans, parce qu’ils ont énormément de choses à apprendre avant d’être autonomes.
Pour combler ça, au sanctuaire, ce sont des mères humaines, de substitution,
qui vont accompagner ces orphelins pour les aider à se développer.
C'est des petits qui, psychologiquement, sont traumatisés à cause de la mort de leur maman.
Ici, le paradis assure cette réhabilitation psychologique des orphelins
afin de leur permettre une bonne croissance, jusqu’à les ramener dans la vie sauvage.
Ils sont pleins d’énergie. Et ça, c’est même un indicateur primordial dans la santé
pour prouver que réellement, tout va bien.
Le sanctuaire va permettre de faire de la sensibilisation.
Bien sûr, ça va sauver quelques dizaines d’individus, ce qui est très bien, ce qui est très important.
Mais ce n’est pas ça qui va sauver directement la population.
Ça va y contribuer par la sensibilisation, notamment des écoles
et donc apprendre aux enfants et puis au grand public en général,
que cette espèce est menacée et qu’il faut la protéger.
Mais attention, quand on parle de milieux naturels,
il faut pas non plus penser qu’on va réintroduire des bonobos qui ont été élevés par des humains
avec des bonobos qui n’ont jamais été élevés par des humains.
Ça pose des questions de santé majeures.
Des bonobos qui ont été élevés par des humains ont pu avoir des traitements antibiotiques, antiparasitaires,
mais aussi être porteurs d’agents pathogènes potentiels pour les populations de bonobos sauvages.
Donc là encore, c’est quelque chose de très compliqué qu’on ne peut pas faire juste comme ça.
Malgré les efforts de conservation,
tous les grands singes d’Afrique de l’est et d’Afrique centrale restent menacés.
Et c’est pour cette raison que la primatologue française Sabrina Krief
continue d’alerter le monde sur l’urgence de la situation.
Ça fait une vingtaine d’années que je travaille en Ouganda et chaque fois,
malgré la longueur du voyage, j’ai vraiment une impatience et aussi une appréhension
à retrouver cette forêt parce que je me demande toujours ce qui va pouvoir avoir changé.
La parc national dans lequel travaille Sabrina Krief
est un des derniers espaces forestiers en Ouganda
où des chimpanzés et d’autres espèces de primates peuvent s’épanouir.
Mais l'augmentation de l’activité humaine dans la région met en danger la vie des animaux.
Cette route, elle traverse le parc national de Kibale.
C’est une route nationale qui est comme une sorte de cicatrice dans cette forêt
et qui entraîne plein de menaces.
À la fois, les risques pour les animaux de se faire renverser, de se faire heurter.
C’est aussi une menace parce que les voyageurs
jettent par les fenêtres leurs bouteilles d’eau.
Les particules de plastique ont contaminé l’environnement et les plantes qu’ils vont consommer
se trouvent polluées par ces particules de plastique.
Le fait que les chimpanzés soient exposés à cette pollution
peut expliquer que certaines femelles ont des problèmes de fertilité.
On a 3 femelles dans le groupe qui ne se reproduisent pas, qui n’ont pas de cycle et qui n’ont pas d’enfants.
On peut évaluer la pollution de l’environnement par l’analyse de l’eau des rivières,
par l’analyse des crottes ou des urines des chimpanzés ou bien par leurs poils.
Le problème qu’on a, c’est qu’on ne peut pas faire de prises de sang aux chimpanzés,
ce sont des chimpanzés sauvages. On garde 10 mètres de distance avec eux
et donc on a besoin d’indices indirects.
Et ces poils nous ont déjà révélé la présence de molécules présentes dans les plastiques
donc c’est un indice de l’exposition et de la contamination
des chimpanzés par les plastiques.
On voit sur ces images, des chimpanzés qui ont la face plate,
qui ont les narines complètement atrophiées, rentrées,
ce qui n’est absolument pas normal.
Ce sont vraiment des malformations congénitales qu’on voit à la naissance
qui ne sont pas liées soit à des problèmes de génétique, soit à des problèmes infectieux
mais qu’on attribue très probablement au fait que pendant la gestation,
la mère chimpanzé expose le fœtus à des pesticides.
Un mélange à la fois de pesticides issus du maïs probablement
et des plantations de thé qui fait qu'il y a une espèce de cocktail chimique
qui est présent dans l’environnement de la mère chimpanzé.
C’est absolument révoltant de penser qu’on implique une telle pression sur la forêt
par l’expansion de l’agriculture, par l’utilisation intensive de polluants chimiques.
L’autre chose qui est vraiment alarmante, c’est que ce sont nos plus proches parents
et que si on observe ça chez les chimpanzés mais aussi chez les babouins,
probablement que nos frères primates nous envoient aussi un signal d’alarme par ces images.
On a quand même une grosse difficulté à avoir des aires protégées efficaces
parce que ce sont des très grandes forêts, parce qu’il y a un manque de moyens,
parce qu'il y a un manque d’infrastructures, un manque de communication et aussi, souvent,
parce qu’il y a un manque de prise en compte des populations locales.
Les personnes qui font de la conservation intégrale, qui la gèrent,
les grandes ONG de conservation ou les gouvernements, en sont conscients.
Et, de plus en plus, font des consultations avec les populations locales.
Mais encore aujourd’hui, ces consultations sont plutôt ce qu’on appelle de “l’acceptabilité”.
C’est-à-dire convaincre les populations riveraines que ce qu’on fait pour eux est bien.
Ce qui est très différent que de chercher à penser le projet au départ
en prenant en considération les pratiques, les usages
qu’ont les populations humaines de leur environnement.
En Ouganda, il y a des solutions, des choses qu’on peut mettre en place.
Bien sûr, enlever les pièges dans la forêt, ramasser les bouteilles mais surtout,
faire de la prévention et également faire en sorte qu’une agriculture
plus durable, biologique, puisse être mise en place.
Tout ça va de pair, bien sûr, avec notre consommation ici.
Si on choisit des produits issus des régions tropicales,
que ce soit le thé bien sûr, mais aussi le café ou le cacao,
qui soient issus d’une agriculture biologique, durable, qui protègent la santé
et les revenus des populations locales, donc commerce équitable, on fait un geste énorme.
Les grands singes sont des espèces charismatiques, emblématiques de la conservation.
En général, le grand public va être plus compréhensif à aller protéger
des bonobos, des chimpanzés ou des gorilles, qu’à aller protéger tel insecte spécifique de telle forêt.
Donc, à travers la conservation des grands singes,
on peut aussi agir à la conservation de la biodiversité en général.
Ces grands singes, qui sont des espèces charismatiques,
sont aussi des espèces qu’on appelle “parapluie”.
Comme son nom l’indique,
quand on protège cette espèce, on en protège beaucoup d’autres
parce qu’elles ont besoin d’un habitat assez complexe pour pouvoir vivre.
Les grands singes ont aussi un rôle écologique majeur.
Ils ont un rôle de disperseurs de graines.
Pour les chimpanzés ou les bonobos par exemple,
ils vont consommer plus d’une centaine d’espèces de plantes différentes.
Et pour une certaine partie d’entre elles, ils vont disséminer les graines,
donc ils ne vont pas les manger, elles vont passer à travers leur appareil digestif
et quand elles vont se retrouver dans leurs crottes à 1 ou 2 km plus loin de là où ils l’ont mangée,
ça va permettre la régénération forestière.
J’ai espoir parce que je pense qu’on ne peut pas les laisser disparaître,
ce sont nos plus proches parents.
Les grands singes sont les espèces les plus proches de l’homme.
Si on n'est pas capables de protéger nos plus proches cousins,
qu'est-ce qu'on va réussir à faire alors avec le reste de la biodiversité ?
Aujourd’hui, il est encore temps de pouvoir réagir.